What's the French electrical supply like over there?
那边的法国电力供应怎么样？
It's good actually. All the equipment's great.
其实还不错。所有的设备都很棒。
Well, now that we can look at 1995 from the safe vantage point of 1996-- we're no longer inside 1995-- I want to point out that at this point, no one in American life seems bigger than life. Not the president, not Michael Jordan, not Courtney or Madonna. And I believe that we witnessed a kind of turning point this past year, when a certain mythic pop group revealed that they're basically just a bunch of aging dullards without any particular magic to them at all.
好吧，现在我们能从1996年这个安全的角度回顾1995年了——我们已经不在1995年之内了——我想指出，在此时此刻，美国生活中似乎没有人看起来是超越现实的。总统不行，迈克尔·乔丹不行，考特尼或麦当娜也不行。我相信在过去的一年里，我们见证了一个转折点，当时一个著名的神话般的流行组合揭示了他们本质上只是一群正在老去的平庸之辈，没有任何特别的魔力。
You know the story, right? The Beatles came out with these big TV documentaries and rare never-before-heard outtakes from their studio sessions. Well, I hold in my hand one of the rare, never-before-heard artifacts spewed forth in the recent deluge. It is a CD, and it's called Beatles - Rare Photos & Interview CD. They put the name "CD" in there, just in case you worry whether is this a CD? Yes, it's a CD.
你知道那个故事吧？披头士乐队推出了这些大型电视纪录片和录音室会议中罕见的、从未公开过的花絮。好吧，我手里正拿着最近涌现出的众多罕见且从未公开的物件之一。这是一张CD，名字叫《披头士——罕见照片与采访CD》。他们把“CD”这个词加进去，以免你担心这到底是不是一张CD？没错，这就是一张CD。
And they've numbered them, because it's such a keepsake. This is number 130,862. It's stamped right here on the front. So it's, you know, a collector's item. And we'll leave aside the telling rare photos, which mostly are the Beatles playing on The Ed Sullivan Show and holding press conferences.
而且他们还给它们编了号，因为这是一种纪念品。这是第130,862号。它就盖在正面这里。所以，你知道的，这算是一件收藏品。我们先不去管那些所谓的罕见照片，它们大部分是披头士在埃德·沙利文秀上的表演以及召开新闻发布会的场景。
In the interviews-- that's what I find so interesting-- the Fab Four basically come across as exhausted, irritated. They prattle on in a mundane way on obvious subjects. They are not especially charming or funny. And they are no more glamorous, really, than you or me. They are exactly human scale. They have been rendered in human scale and not one inch bigger.
在采访中——我发现这才是最有趣的地方——这四位大明星基本上给人一种疲惫、烦躁的感觉。他们以平庸的方式在显而易见的话题上喋喋不休。他们并不特别迷人，也不风趣。而且说真的，他们并不比你我更光鲜亮丽。他们完全是人类的尺度。他们被还原成了人类的尺度，没有一丁点被夸大。
Are you going to wear these Hong Kong suits that you've had made?
你要穿那些你定做的香港西装吗？
George and I haven't had any made. Paul's had one. That's all.
乔治和我没有定做过。保罗做了一套。就那样。
Now, Paul, you've bought a Chinese suit?
现在，保罗，你买了一套中式西装？
Yes, it's true. Two, I got.
是的，是真的。我买了两套。
Did you? How much did you pay for them?
是吗？你花了多少钱？
It wasn't very dear. About 10 quid, I think. Yeah. Oh, it was great, actually, because somebody said, "You've got to haggle and get the prices down." So some little fellow was selling some ornaments. And he wanted $160 for them. No, he was selling a watch. That's it. He wanted 160 Hong Kong dollars for it. So I kept saying to him, "No that's not right. Not right. $100, that's right." You know?
不太贵。我想大概10英镑吧。是的。哦，其实这很棒，因为有人说：“你得砍价，把价格压下来。”所以有个小伙子在卖一些装饰品。他要价160美元。不，他是在卖一块手表。对，就是这样。他要价160港元。所以我一直对他说：“不，这不对。不对。100美元，那才对。”你知道吧？
Happy birthday, Ringo. Any good presents?
生日快乐，林戈。收到什么好礼物了吗？
Um, a few, you know. Quite a few.
嗯，有一些，你知道的。还不少。
Any in particular?
有什么特别的吗？
No.
没有。
Paul, do you feel that your vacation here in Los Angeles was a success even though you didn't have very much privacy?
保罗，你觉得你在洛杉矶的假期成功吗，尽管你没有太多的隐私？
Yeah.
是的。
Did you mind the girls on the hill?
你在意山上的那些女孩吗？
No.
不。
Well, what was your most enjoyable part of your vacation?
那么，你假期里最享受的部分是什么？
Just lazing around.
只是懒洋洋地待着。
What is the sort of stuff they like over there on the Hit Parade?
那边流行音乐排行榜上大家喜欢什么样的东西？
Uh, wilder stuff, I think. We stuck in a wilder number.
呃，更狂野的东西，我想。我们录了一首更狂野的曲子。
They go for the Elvis Presley type of stuff, there, do they? I mean, they go for the older rock and roll stuff?
他们那边比较喜欢埃尔维斯·普雷斯利那种风格的东西吗？我的意思是，他们喜欢老派的摇滚乐吗？
I think so, yeah, a bit more.
我想是吧，稍微多一点。
By the way, from WBEZ in Chicago, this is Your Radio Playhouse. Today, the year in the life of one neighborhood and a generation in the life of one church. Unusual stories of this, our American life, as always. Stay with us.
顺便说一下，这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》。今天，我们将讲述一个社区的一年和一个教会一代人的故事。像往常一样，讲述我们美国生活中不寻常的故事。请留下来。
Is this music, is this little tape the most irritating thing we have ever put onto the-- OK, I'm just going to stop it-- the most irritating thing we have ever done? All right, enough of that.
这音乐，这段小磁带是我们放过的最令人恼火的东西吗——好吧，我要关掉它了——这是我们做过的最令人恼火的事情吗？好了，到此为止。
Well, other radio and television programs have spent much of the last week trying to summarize the past year. We have seen or heard the year in music, the year in films, the year in world events and world politics, the year in fashion. I'm sure somewhere out there, there's a cheese magazine that's done the year in cheese. You know. It was a big year for Roquefort, or-- I don't even know any cheese names. It was a big year for something.
好吧，其他广播和电视节目在过去的一周里花了很多时间试图总结过去的一年。我们已经看到或听到了音乐年、电影年、世界大事和世界政治年、时尚年。我肯定在某个地方，有一本关于奶酪的杂志做过奶酪年总结。你知道的。那是罗克福尔奶酪的大年，或者——我甚至不知道任何奶酪的名字。那是某样东西的大年。
And trying to get a sense of the year by means of these big summary year-end stories, it's like trying to get a sense of the United States by flying across the country in a jet and looking out the window. You see lots of pretty colors and lots of interesting shapes, but the people look like ants. Well, at this, Your Radio Playhouse , we prefer the camera to move in a little closer for a better look. And so now that we have some distance, some objectivity on the past year-- we have, what is it, five days of complete objectivity. We've invited Claudia Perez to tell us what the year was like in one small Chicago neighborhood.
通过这些宏大的年度总结故事试图去理解这一年，就像坐喷气式飞机飞越全国并从窗外向外看，试图去理解美国一样。你会看到许多漂亮的颜色和许多有趣的形状，但人们看起来像蚂蚁。嗯，在我们的《你的广播剧场》，我们更喜欢摄影机能靠得近一点，以便看个究竟。所以现在我们有了一些距离感，对过去的一年有了一些客观性——我们有了，怎么说呢，五天的完全客观。我们邀请了克劳迪娅·佩雷斯来告诉我们芝加哥一个小社区的一年是怎样的。
And Claudia is a high school student. She's 18 years old. And we hooked up with her through a community group called Street-Level Video. And usually teenagers come to Street-Level Video to make TV stories about their lives and their neighborhoods. This is Claudia's first radio story.
克劳迪娅是一名高中生。她今年18岁。我们通过一个叫“街头影像”的社区团体联系上了她。通常青少年会来到“街头影像”制作关于他们生活和社区的电视故事。这是克劳迪娅的第一个广播故事。
When people around the country think of Chicago, most of them do not realize how Mexican this city is. But Chicago has more Mexicans than any other United States city except for Los Angeles. It's over 1 million people. And Little Village is the neighborhood that most new Mexican immigrants come to. Claudia is from this neighborhood and says that the place to go, if you really want to understand what the neighborhood's like, is 26th Street. She gave me a tour last week.
当全国各地的人们想到芝加哥时，大多数人并没有意识到这座城市有多么墨西哥化。但芝加哥拥有的墨西哥人数量超过了除洛杉矶以外的任何其他美国城市。人口超过100万。小村庄社区是大多数新墨西哥移民落脚的地方。克劳迪娅就来自这个社区，她说如果你真的想了解这个社区是什么样，就去26街。上周她带我逛了一圈。
Everyone comes to 26th Street. It's a pretty busy place. There's Lalo's, Aguascalientes, and the discount mall. There's a parking lot at Church's Chicken where people meet up. The loto men are on every other corner selling corn, cucumbers, tamales, Mexican antojitos. It's as busy as Michigan Avenue downtown.
每个人都会来26街。这是一个相当繁忙的地方。这里有拉洛餐厅、阿瓜斯卡连特斯餐厅和折扣商场。教堂炸鸡店的停车场是人们碰面的地方。街头小贩在每个街角卖玉米、黄瓜、墨西哥粽子和墨西哥小吃。这里就像市中心的密歇根大道一样繁忙。
So there's Rosie's Bakery.
那里有罗西面包店。
[SPEAKING SPANISH], Supermercados, Upe Travel, Rio Grande Music.
（西班牙语），超市，Upe旅行社，里奥格兰德音乐商店。
Lowrider Magazine on sale here.
《低底盘车》杂志在这里有售。
There's a big archway on 26th Street, near the discount mall. The clock on it, donated by the Mexican government, stopped working a few weeks after it was installed. There are also green and white and red lights arranged in the shape of the Mexican flag, but the green and white ones have been burned out for years.
在26街靠近折扣商场的地方有一个大拱门。上面那个由墨西哥政府捐赠的时钟，在安装几周后就停止工作了。还有绿、白、红三色的灯光排列成墨西哥国旗的形状，但绿色和白色的灯泡已经烧坏多年了。
That little thing right there says, "Bienvenidos a Little Village." That's when you're entering Little Village. You know what a lot of gang-bangers do when they pass this thing? They cross themselves. They'd say [SPEAKING SPANISH] because they're leaving the neighborhood.
那个小东西上写着“欢迎来到小村庄”。那是当你进入小村庄的时候。你知道很多帮派成员经过这个标志时会做什么吗？他们会画十字。他们会说（西班牙语），因为他们正在离开这个社区。
Because they're leaving the place that they're safe. In the summer, people come to 26th Street and cruise around when they're bored.
因为他们离开了让他们感到安全的地方。夏天，人们来到26街，无聊的时候就会开车到处转悠。
You come here, cruise for a while, kill time, see who's around, pick up some liquor, and go to the lake. I talked to this girl in the record store about why girls come down here to cruise.
你来到这里，兜兜风，打发时间，看看周围有什么人，买点酒，然后去湖边。我采访了唱片店里的这个女孩，问她为什么女孩们会到这里来兜风。
To check out the guys, I guess.
我想是看看男生吧。
There's a lot of cute guys. And sometimes it's sad because they're gang-bangers. But they're the finest ones.
有很多可爱的男生。有时候这很令人难过，因为他们是帮派成员。但他们确实是最帅的。
Even if you don't want to really socialize or hang around with them, at least you'll take a look at them. You just get this tingly feeling inside.
即使你不想真的去社交或和他们混在一起，至少你会看他们一眼。你会有一种内心颤动的感觉。
You can't pass on 26th Street without noticing Rossi Brothers. They have beautiful furniture, and this is the stuff people in the neighborhood want to buy-- the people with money, and the people without.
你经过26街时不可能不注意到罗西兄弟家具店。他们有漂亮的家具，而这些正是社区里的人们想要买的东西——有钱的和没钱的人都想买。
And whatever you've heard about the terrible shape of the nation's retail economy, 26th Street is doing fine. According to the Chamber of Commerce in Little Village, in 1995 the number of stores in the neighborhood actually increased 20%. The salesmen at Rossi Brothers had a good year.
无论你听到过多少关于国家零售经济状况多么糟糕的消息，26街的表现都很好。根据小村庄商会的说法，1995年该社区的商店数量实际上增加了20%。罗西兄弟家具店的销售员们度过了不错的一年。
This is the most successful year. We've been here 40 years. So why business is better? I don't know. Maybe it's because our fathers are retired and we're younger.
这是最成功的一年。我们在这里已经40年了。那么为什么生意更好呢？我不知道。也许是因为我们的父亲退休了，而我们更年轻。
There's a definite transformation in the area. All the property's becoming worthwhile. All the empty vacant lots, they're putting new houses there, new construction. So this is becoming a vital part of the city.
该地区确实发生了转变。所有的房产都变得有价值了。所有的空地都在盖新房子，进行新的建设。所以这正在成为城市中充满活力的一部分。
Over at the discount mall, some stores had a good year. For some, it was so-so. The discount mall is probably 40 or 50 stores packed into an old department store building. Narrow aisles and things stacked way over your head. Spanish music and the Virgin of Guadalupe everywhere. She was on T-shirts and framed pictures. She was on a clock surrounded by tiny colored lights.
在折扣商场那边，有些商店生意不错。有些则平平淡淡。折扣商场大概是由40到50家商店挤在一栋旧百货大楼里组成的。狭窄的过道里东西堆到了你的头顶上方。到处都是西班牙语音乐和瓜达卢佩圣母的画像。她的画像印在T恤和相框上。她还出现在被彩色小灯包围的时钟上。
All the stores basically sell the same things-- things from Mexico, from LA, like the Ben Davis suits, cholo shirts. Down the hall is one of the leather stores. Three girls were just sitting there, eating Chinese food. One of them said the most unforgettable thing that happened to her this year was a sale to someone who was Polish.
所有的店基本上都卖同样的东西——来自墨西哥或洛杉矶的商品，比如本·戴维斯工装裤、乔洛风格的衬衫。走廊深处是一家皮具店。三个女孩正坐在那里吃中餐。其中一个说，今年发生在她身上最难忘的事情就是卖给了一个波兰人东西。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Usually, she said, the Poles who come to her store look but don't buy. They worry that the Mexican merchants don't give them the best price. The merchants see their caution differently.
她说，通常来她店里的波兰人只会看看而不买。他们担心墨西哥商家没有给他们最好的价格。而商人们看待他们的谨慎态度则不同。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Tacanos. She's saying they're cheap. Over the years, so many Mexicans have done well in Chicago that lots of them have moved away from this neighborhood to the suburbs. This woman said 80% of her customers this year were Mexicans who've moved to the suburbs but who have come back here to shop.
吝啬鬼。她说他们很吝啬。这些年来，很多墨西哥人在芝加哥发展得很好，以至于他们中的许多人都搬离了这个社区，去了郊区。这位女士说她今年80%的顾客都是搬到郊区但又回来购物的墨西哥人。
They don't forget where they come from. In the hallway, we found this man from the suburbs. He says he comes here to get what the Mexicano wears.
他们没有忘记自己来自哪里。在走廊里，我们遇到了这位来自郊区的男士。他说他来这里是为了买墨西哥人穿的东西。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He says it feels like you're in Mexico here. He comes here to see the paisanos. He came here with his friends so they could get to know Little Village.
他说在这里感觉就像在墨西哥一样。他来这里是为了看看同胞。他带朋友来是为了让他们了解小村庄。
1995 was fine for him, he said. He finally got a stable job in a restaurant. He doesn't have to be jumping from factory to factory.
他说，1995年对他来说很好。他终于在一家餐馆找到了一份稳定的工作。他不必再在不同的工厂之间跳来跳去了。
Over near the pet store, the staff of CJ's Clothing is almost all teenagers. One boy is 17, originally from Mexico, from Michoacan. He works but doesn't go to school. This year he met this girl in Mexico who lived in Chicago. He liked her and followed her over here. Eventually, it didn't work. But he stayed here, and now he is making money to help out his family.
在宠物店附近，CJ服装店的员工几乎全是青少年。有个男孩17岁，原本来自墨西哥的米却肯州。他打工，但不去上学。今年他在墨西哥遇到了这个住在芝加哥的女孩。他喜欢她，就跟着她来到了这里。最终，这段关系没成。但他留了下来，现在正在赚钱贴补家用。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He says he misses his family in Mexico, but if he was there, he says, he'd just be doing drugs instead of making money to help his family.
他说他想念在墨西哥的家人，但他说，如果他在那边的话，他可能已经在吸毒了，而不是在这里赚钱帮补家人。
His little cousin Ricardo is his interpreter. He translates everything for him. Ricardo had a couple of exciting moments in 1995, like when he helped the police catch a thief at the discount mall. The officers were just standing around watching videos on a store TV, when Ricardo told them that a lady was stealing one of those club things you use to protect your car. But overall, Ricardo summed up 1995 in one word.
他的小表弟里卡多是他的翻译。他为他翻译一切。里卡多在1995年有过几个激动人心的时刻，比如他曾帮助警察在折扣商场抓到了一名小偷。当时警察只是站在旁边看商店电视里的录像，里卡多告诉他们，一位女士正在偷那种保护汽车的防盗锁。但总的来说，里卡多用一个词总结了1995年。
Bad.
糟糕。
Bad? Why bad?
糟糕？为什么糟糕？
I don't know. Boring.
我不知道。无聊。
Boring? Why has it been boring?
无聊？为什么会无聊？
My brother. He bores me. When he goes to places, he doesn't take me anywhere. He doesn't take me with him.
我哥哥。他让我觉得无聊。当他去什么地方时，他不带我去任何地方。他不带我一起去。
And he's older than you?
而且他比你大？
I'm nine and he's 15.
我九岁，他15岁。
But when he was 13, would he take you with him? Was there a time when he would take you all the time?
但是当他13岁的时候，他会带你一起去吗？有没有过一段时间他总是带你一起去？
No.
没有。
No, he never took you.
没有，他从不带你。
Nowhere.
哪儿也不带。
Miguel is a salesperson at CJ's. When I saw him, I knew for sure that he would speak English. I could just tell. He's 19, has a goatee, is tall, [INAUDIBLE] complexion. I asked him how his year was.
米格尔是CJ店的一名销售员。当我看到他时，我就确信他会说英语。我一看就知道了。他19岁，留着山羊胡，个子很高，肤色（听不清）。我问他今年过得怎么样。
This year's been my best year so far. Maybe meeting some more girls, for example. That's about it.
今年是我迄今为止最好的一年。比如认识了一些女孩。就这些了。
He had a wish for 1996.
他有一个1996年的愿望。
Maybe hook up with some girl that I want right now. No names right now.
也许能勾搭上我现在想要的某个女孩。现在不提名字。
Does she know yet that you want to go out with her?
她知道你想和她约会了吗？
Yeah, she knows.
是的，她知道。
When's the first date going to happen?
第一次约会什么时候开始？
When her father lets her out.
等她父亲放她出来的时候。
How old is she?
她多大了？
She's like 18, 17.
大概18、17岁吧。
And they don't let her out yet?
他们还不让她出门吗？
Not at all. I guess she's got one of those strict parents.
完全不让。我想她父母管得挺严。
We talk to Miguel for a while. In '96, he'll graduate from DeVry to become an electronic technician. He doesn't party. He doesn't like trouble in the street. And before long, he asks Claudia for her phone number.
我们和米格尔聊了一会儿。在96年，他将从德锐大学毕业，成为一名电子技术员。他不参加派对。他不喜欢街头的麻烦。不久之后，他向克劳迪娅要了电话号码。
Give me your number too. Why don't you give me your number, and I'll call you too. And when you're famous, I'll be famous with you too.
也给我你的号码。你为什么不把号码给我，我也给你打电话。等你出名了，我也能跟着你一起出名。
All right. I'll give you-- this is my pager number.
好吧。我给你——这是我的寻呼机号码。
I told him I wanted to be a fashion designer and a writer someday, and he said--
我告诉他我以后想当服装设计师和作家，他说——
OK, you can write a book about me.
好啊，你可以写一本关于我的书。
Yeah, I'm going to write a book.
对，我打算写一本书。
About me, though, right?
写我，对吧？
We headed over to the cosmetics counter. It appeared to this correspondent that Miguel wanted Claudia's phone number for a date.
我们走到化妆品柜台。这位通讯员觉得米格尔向克劳迪娅要电话号码是为了约会。
I thought he just wanted it for business.
我以为他只是为了谈生意。
He is definitely calling you.
他绝对会打给你的。
Well, I don't know. We'll see if he calls.
嗯，我不知道。到时候看他打不打吧。
Next, we went to Los Comales. It's open 24 hours. It's the place where everyone goes when they get a hunger attack. I usually stop by at 12:00 or 1:00 in the morning. They have good tortas, the best tortas. I won't eat tortas from anywhere else. If I'm on a diet, I'll just drink a licuado de fresa instead of a torta.
接下来，我们去了Los Comales。它是24小时营业的。那是每个人饿了的时候都会去的地方。我通常在凌晨12点或1点左右过来。他们的烤肉三明治很好吃，是最好吃的。我不吃其他地方的烤肉三明治。如果我在节食，我就喝草莓奶昔代替三明治。
It's a noisy, friendly place with bright orange booths, a loud jukebox and the blenders going nearly nonstop, making licuados. At one table was a guy with short hair and a big black and white Adidas jacket sitting with his girlfriend. He had a bad year.
这是一个嘈杂、友好的地方，有亮橙色的卡座、声音很大的点唱机，还有几乎不停歇搅拌着草莓奶昔的搅拌机。在一张桌子旁，坐着一个留着短发、穿着黑白大阿迪达斯外套的年轻人，正和他女友在一起。他过得很糟糕。
It ain't been good, man. I got  fired from my job.
过得一点也不好，伙计。我被公司开除了。
Why'd you get fired?
你为什么被开除？
Because I lied on my application. Because when they ask you, have you been convicted of felonies, I put no. And later on--
因为我在申请表上撒了谎。当他们问你有没有重罪定罪记录时，我填了没有。后来——
They found out.
他们发现了。
Yeah. It's because somebody went into the office and they kind of told on me or something.
是啊。是因为有人去了办公室，告了我的密之类的。
They wanted you to get fired, I think. Can you say something besides losing your job that you want to forget, that happened to you this year?
我想他们是想让你被开除。除了丢掉工作，你还能说说今年发生的其他你想忘掉的事情吗？
This year? Well, I just out of jail.
今年？嗯，我刚出狱。
Did it help you in any way, being in jail? Like, straighten up your head?
坐牢对你有任何帮助吗？比如，让你变得清醒点？
He was quiet for a second. His girlfriend shook her head, no.
他沉默了一会儿。他女朋友摇了摇头，表示没有。
It didn't help you? Are you still stubborn?
没有帮助吗？你还是很固执吗？
Right. The jail ain't for getting you straight. It just makes you worse.
对。监狱不是让人变好的地方。它只会让你变得更糟。
What do you plan to do for '96?
你对96年有什么打算？
I don't know. I've still got my cases pending.
我不知道。我的案子还在审理中。
A girl sitting with her friends also had a pretty bad year. Part of it was that she was going to Mexico to go visit her grandfather for the first time, and she received a call from some relatives informing her that her grandfather had been killed.
一个和朋友坐在一起的女孩也度过了相当糟糕的一年。部分原因是因为她本打算去墨西哥第一次看望祖父，却接到了亲戚的电话，告知她祖父被杀害了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She said it will always stay with her, deep down inside, because she never got the chance to meet her grandfather. But she said this year has made her even stronger. Now she knows that she has to stay in school and continue her education. Now she's working. She says she's learned you've got to fight for what you want in this life. She knows that it's not going to fall from the sky.
她说这件事会一直藏在她内心深处，因为她从未有机会见到祖父。但她说今年让她变得更加坚强了。现在她知道必须留在学校继续接受教育。现在她在工作。她说她学到，在这个世界上，你必须为你想要的东西去奋斗。她知道这些东西不会从天而降。
The crime rate, it's low. It's a lot lower. As far as 26th Street, the merchants, there's hardly any robberies and very few thefts. The gang situations, that's being curbed.
犯罪率很低。低多了。说到26街，商家几乎没有什么抢劫案，盗窃案也寥寥无几。帮派问题也得到了遏制。
We found two of the policemen who patrol 26th Street standing at a graphic design office. They said community policing is one of the main reasons crime rates are going down here. Now people are more willing to sign complaints and appear in court. It didn't used to be that way.
我们发现两名在26街巡逻的警察正站在一家平面设计办公室旁。他们说社区警务是这里犯罪率下降的主要原因之一。现在人们更愿意签署投诉并出庭作证。以前可不是这样。
When I asked this cop to tell us about the most dramatic thing that happened to him this year, his partner said, "What about that jewelry store robbery?"
当我请这位警察告诉我们他今年经历的最戏剧性的事情时，他的搭档说：“珠宝店抢劫案那件事呢？”
Well, I don't think that's dramatic. I've seen robberies. That was just a typical robbery. I mean, it could be dramatic to somebody else, or the person that got robbed. But to me, it's just an everyday occurrence for me. So it doesn't phase me anymore. Or as far as people getting shot and killed. I'm used to it.
嗯，我不觉得那有什么戏剧性。我见过很多抢劫。那只是典型的抢劫案。我是说，对别人，或者对被抢的人来说可能很戏剧性。但对我来说，这只是家常便饭。所以我已经不再有什么感觉了。至于人们被枪杀也是一样。我已经习惯了。
But something did happen to him that was more dramatic than a robbery or a shooting.
但确实发生了一件比抢劫或枪击对他来说更具戏剧性的事情。
Just dramatic-- I bought a brand-new home. Well, I guess it's not dramatic, but--
就是戏剧性——我买了一套全新的房子。好吧，我想这不算戏剧性，但是——
It's good. That's my dream, is to have my own house. I never had a house. I always lived in apartments. That's nice.
那很好。拥有自己的房子是我的梦想。我从来没住过自己的房子。我一直住公寓。那太棒了。
Well, I guess, hard work, and-- it's on the Southwest side of Chicago. And it's a split-level home, like a suburban-type home. It's a nice home, side drive, four bedrooms, two-and-a-half-car garage. Expensive. I have a lot of police officer friends that live in that neighborhood. So I guess that's what made me buy over there.
嗯，我想，努力工作，而且——房子在芝加哥的西南区。是一个错层式住宅，像郊区那样的房子。那是个不错的房子，有侧车道，四间卧室，两个半车位车库。很贵。我有很多警察朋友都住在那个社区。所以我想这就是我买在那边的原因。
For all the stories you hear about how terrible life is in poor, inner-city neighborhoods, one of the most striking things about 26th Street is how many people told us they'd had a really good year last year.
尽管你听到的故事都说贫穷的内城区生活多么糟糕，但关于26街最引人注目的事情之一是，很多人告诉我们，他们去年过得非常好。
We met this young couple who had a baby and a two-year-old daughter. I asked if I could interview the husband, because he was the one carrying the baby. So he turns around and asks his wife if it was OK with her. And she said yes. I just totally fell in love with that.
我们遇到了一对年轻夫妇，他们有一个婴儿和一个两岁的女儿。我问是否可以采访这位丈夫，因为是他抱着孩子。于是他转过身问他妻子这样行不行。她答应了。我完全被这一幕打动了。
When we asked him what was so good about this past year, he said:
当我们问他过去这一年有什么好事情时，他说：
Everything. My daughter's been growing happily and healthy. Real healthy. Steady growing. Everything's been nice. We've got nice blessings this year, you know. We've been together for a long time. We've already been together for four years. And they say they don't last, young couples, so we've really been lasting together. So that's real memorable.
一切都好。我女儿长得很开心，很健康。真的很健康。稳步成长。一切都很美好。我们今年得到了很多祝福，你知道的。我们在一起很长时间了。我们已经在一起四年了。人们常说年轻情侣长久不了，所以我们能一直在一起真的很不容易。这非常值得纪念。
He's 22 and she's 21, Mario and Alice Ramirez. Like any parents, some of their biggest events of 1995 involved their kids. For example:
他22岁，她21岁，马里奥和爱丽丝·拉米雷斯。像所有父母一样，他们1995年最重大的事件都与孩子有关。例如：
There are bad words she says. That's real cute. One of those bad words she says, they just come out. It's bad. I don't want to say it.
她说脏话。真的很可爱。她说出的那些脏话，是脱口而出的。很糟糕。我不想说。
When did she say it?
她什么时候说的？
Oh, yesterday. Yesterday, right?
哦，昨天。昨天，对吧？
Tell us all the story. Where were you guys?
给我们讲讲经过。你们当时在哪？
Well, we're all sitting down, and she don't really talk that much, and all of a sudden she just came out. She got mad at me and called me a real bad word. She just goes, hey, you-- and everyone started laughing, so it was nice.
嗯，我们都在坐着，她平时不太说话，突然间她就说了出来。她对我生气，骂了我一句很难听的脏话。她就说，嘿，你这个——然后大家都笑了起来，所以感觉挺好的。
Was it in Spanish or in English?
是用西班牙语还是英语说的？
Spanish. No, it was in English actually.
西班牙语。不，其实是英语。
I want to know.
我想知道。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Pussy.
懦夫（Pussy）。
She's just about to turn three, and this happened at Christmas dinner. You know, Mexican families are big. They were all there, and they all laughed.
她快满三岁了，这事发生在圣诞晚宴上。你知道，墨西哥家庭人很多。他们都在场，大家都笑了。
When we asked about '96, Mario said next year was going to be nicer. Every year will be nicer, he said.
当我们问起96年时，马里奥说明年会更好。他说，每一年都会更好。
He held the baby, his wife took her two-year-old daughter's hand, and they walked away down 26th Street in the snow.
他抱着婴儿，他妻子牵着两岁女儿的手，他们在雪地里沿着26街走远了。
[MUSIC]
[音乐]
Claudia.
克劳迪娅。
Yes?
什么？
We should explain what music this is.
我们应该解释一下这是什么音乐。
Well, this is a tape we bought at the discount mall. It's called Tracks are for Kids.
嗯，这是我们在打折商场买的一盘磁带。叫《Tracks are for Kids》。
The box of it looks like the cereal box, Trix are for kids, with the little bunny.
它的盒子看起来就像那个麦片盒子，Trix are for kids，上面有那只小兔子。
It's a mix tape. The song here is just to give you a little taste of what the Latinos in the South Side and everywhere else listen to.
这是一盘混合磁带。这里的歌只是为了让你尝尝南区和其他地方的拉丁裔都在听什么。
OK, doesn't this music sound more vital, more alive, than the certain music of a certain group of aging baby-boom '60s era-- you, you, beloved listener, you be the judge.
好吧，这段音乐听起来是不是比那些老龄化的60年代婴儿潮一代的特定音乐——你们，你们这些亲爱的听众，你们自己来评判吧。
[MUSIC --  "ALL YOU NEED IS LOVE" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐——披头士乐队的《ALL YOU NEED IS LOVE》]
John and Paul, you recently produced a record by the Silkie.
约翰和保罗，你们最近制作了一张Silkie乐队的唱片。
Yes.
是的。
Do you think you'll do any more?
你们觉得还会再做吗？
Yes.
会。
Do any of you go to church?
你们中间有人去教堂吗？
No.
没有。
Do you want to buy anything in Australia?
你们想在澳大利亚买什么东西吗？
Yes, definitely.
是的，绝对想。
Like what?
比如什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Do you ever have your hair cut?
你们会去剪头发吗？
Of course.
当然。
Do you ever get irritated because you can't get above the noise of the people screaming at the shows?
你是否曾经因为无法盖过演出中人们的尖叫声而感到烦躁？
No.
没有。
Have you met any interesting American girls?
你有没有遇到过什么有趣的美国女孩？
Not yet.
还没有。
What do you think of the police protection you've been receiving here in the city?
你觉得你在这里受到的警察保护怎么样？
It's marvelous.
非常棒。
Are the crowds as large as you expected?
人群有你预期的那么多吗？
No.
没有。
Well, my New Year's resolution this past New Year's was to finish this next story and finally get it on the radio. It's a story that I began over a year ago, and it involved many, many other people. It's one of these stories that actually involved an entire church. And for 10 months, I have not been able to walk down 57th Street without looking over my shoulder in fear that I'm going to run into one of these people, because I had not finished the story. But now I am proud to say, the story, it is here. It is here, and it is here to stay. Though I guess that doesn't really mean anything when you say it on the radio. Well, at least it's here, and I will be set free.
嗯，我上个新年的新年愿望是完成这篇故事，并最终把它放到广播里播出。这是一年多前我就开始写的故事，涉及许多、许多其他人。这是一个实际上涉及到整个教会的故事。在过去的10个月里，我一直不敢走在第57街上，总是担心会碰到这些人中的某一个，因为我还没有写完这个故事。但现在我很自豪地说，故事，它就在这里。它在这里，而且它会一直留在这里。虽然我想当你通过广播说出来时，这并没有什么真正的意义。嗯，至少它就在这里，我也将获得解脱。
The story does involve this entire church, a historic church here in Chicago. And we'll get to that part. But first we have to talk about how it begins, because it begins with this woman named Karen Hutt. And Karen Hutt is normally the director of religious education at this church. It's the First Unitarian Church of Chicago.
这个故事确实涉及整个教会，即芝加哥这里的一座历史悠久的教会。我们会讲到那一部分。但首先我们必须谈谈它是如何开始的，因为它始于一位名叫凯伦·赫特的女士。凯伦·赫特通常是该教会宗教教育的主任。它是芝加哥第一一位论派教会。
And one Sunday morning, a while back, I'll admit, when the senior minister was away, Karen Hutt did a guest sermon. And she talked about a very unusual experience that she had as a child. Karen Hutt was the first black child to integrate the Philadelphia public schools. This was in the 1960s.
很久以前的一个周日早晨，我得承认，当资深牧师不在时，凯伦·赫特做了一次客座布道。她谈到了她童年时一段非常不寻常的经历。凯伦·赫特是第一位进入费城公立学校的黑人儿童。那是在20世纪60年代。
So first of all, for a moment, let's set our minds back away from the current debate over quotas and overturning affirmative action. Let's turn our minds back now to a more hopeful moment in American race relations. And in her sermon, she talked about what went right and what went wrong in this thing that she witnessed herself.
所以首先，让我们暂时把思绪从当前关于配额和推翻平权行动的辩论中拉回来。让我们现在把思绪转向美国种族关系中一个更充满希望的时刻。在她的布道中，她谈到了她在亲眼见证的这件事中，哪些是正确的，哪些是错误的。
And what happened was that her family moved to a white, Jewish neighborhood. And she enrolled in the white public school there.
发生的事情是，她的家人搬到了一个白人犹太人社区。她在那里的一所白人公立学校注册入学。
We were a part of the experiment. There were about three black families, and lots of good will and excitement about this experiment. So I talked about my friend Randy Goldstein in the sermon, about how she and I were really good friends, and our parents got to know each other real well. And they were learning how to play pinochle, and we were learning how to play Mah Jongg and eating matzo ball soup, and they were eating collard greens. So we were this perfect notion of how we were going to all live together in multicultural heaven.
我们是那个实验的一部分。大约有三个黑人家庭，大家对这个实验充满了善意和兴奋。所以在布道中我谈到了我的朋友兰迪·戈尔茨坦，谈到她和我如何成为真正的好朋友，我们的父母也互相了解得很深。他们学着打皮诺克纸牌，我们学着打麻将，吃着逾越节无酵饼汤，而他们吃着羽衣甘蓝。所以对于我们如何共同生活在一个多元文化的乐园里，我们当时有着这种完美的构想。
But then one day, after about the fifth or sixth, or maybe it was the ninth or tenth black family moved into the neighborhood, Randy said she was moving. And I said, why are you moving, Randy? And she says, well, my mother says it's getting a little dark around here. So I realized that she wasn't really talking about an eclipse. It was probably about me and my color and my neighbors.
但后来有一天，在第五个、第六个，或者可能是第九个或第十个黑人家庭搬进社区后，兰迪说她要搬走了。我说，兰迪，你为什么要搬走？她说，嗯，我妈妈说这附近变得有点黑了。所以我意识到她并不是在谈论日食。她可能是在说我和我的肤色，以及我的邻居们。
Karen, let me ask you. Did you feel like you were a guinea pig? Or did you feel like you were able to have a normal life?
凯伦，让我问你。你是否觉得自己像个实验品？还是说你觉得你可以拥有正常的生活？
Well, I know in the very beginning when we moved to this neighborhood-- which I was really resisting, because all my friends were the other neighborhood, the old neighborhood, not the new neighborhood. And the new neighborhood was something for my father to tell his friends about. I'd hear him on the phone and he'd be talking to his friends and saying, yeah, man, we're the only ones out here. And I'd listen to him like, the only ones out where? What was this all about for him?
嗯，我知道刚开始我们搬到这个社区时——我其实非常抵触，因为我所有的朋友都在另一个街区，老街区，而不是新街区。而这个新街区是我父亲可以向朋友炫耀的东西。我会在电话里听到他，他会和朋友们说，是啊，伙计，我们是这里唯一的人。我听着他的话，心想，在什么地方唯一？这对父亲来说到底意味着什么？
So clearly, for my parents, it was a big move to a really big house and a lot of prestige and all this kind of thing. But for me, I did feel like an experiment, because people I didn't know in the neighborhood would stop and smile at me, and say they're glad that I'm there, and do all these kinds of things. Even sometimes giving out little candies to us, like we were some kind of prize. But that all made me always feel a little uncomfortable, because I could never trust that it was going to be real. Because as soon as I would get comfortable and trust, it would be shattered by a comment or a stare or a glare or people following us around or saying things about us. But all that sort of changed when the numbers changed. And that's what really made a big difference.
显然，对于我的父母来说，这搬进了一所很大的房子，有了很高的声望，诸如此类。但对我来说，我确实感到自己像个实验品，因为街区里我不认识的人会停下来对我微笑，说很高兴我在这里，并做所有这些事。有时甚至分发一些小糖果给我们，就像我们是什么奖品一样。但所有这些总是让我感到有点不舒服，因为我永远无法相信它是真实的。因为一旦我感到舒适和信任，它就会被一句评论、一个凝视、一个瞪眼，或者人们跟着我们，或者说关于我们的事情所粉碎。但当人数改变时，所有这一切都改变了。而这才是真正带来巨大差异的地方。
It's interesting how few the numbers have to be for it to change. How many African-American families had moved in before the total environment change.
很有意思，人数要少到什么程度才会改变。在整体环境改变之前，有多少非裔美国人家庭搬进来了。
Well, it was maybe 50%. When it was 50%. Integration for a lot of white people-- I found it to be like one black family in the whole neighborhood, that's integration. But for African-Americans, we like the idea of 50-50. That seemed about right. So when it got to be 50-50, the integration dream was dashed. It was just gone.
嗯，可能达到50%的时候。当达到50%时。对于很多白人来说——我发现这就像整个社区里有一个黑人家庭，那就是融合。但对于非裔美国人来说，我们喜欢50对50的理念。这看起来似乎很合适。所以当达到50对50时，融合的梦想就破灭了。它就这样消失了。
Because whites fled.
因为白人逃离了。
Whites fled. And we have to also realize that the real estate agents did a lot to contribute to this. It wasn't just people leaving. They were actually offered a lot. But the thing that I found curious was that all the blacks that were moving in had much more material wealth or better jobs. Like, most of the Jewish people in the neighborhood were teachers and social workers, and our families were politicians and judges and lawyers and doctors. And we found it rather curious that they wouldn't want to live with us. Because we knew it wasn't economic at that point.
白人逃离了。我们也必须意识到，房地产经纪人在很大程度上促成了这一点。不仅仅是人们离开。他们实际上得到了很多优惠。但我感到好奇的是，所有搬进来的黑人都拥有更多的物质财富或更好的工作。比如，社区里的犹太人大多数是教师和社会工作者，而我们的家庭是政治家、法官、律师和医生。我们觉得他们不想和我们住在一起相当奇怪。因为我们知道当时那并不是经济原因。
Did you ever feel angry at your parents for putting you in this situation?
你是否曾经因为父母把你置于这种境地而感到愤怒？
Yeah, I was very angry about it. But I'm really proud about it now, because it was an exciting thing to be a part of. I'm smarter for it, I think. But I was angry at the time.
是的，我当时对此非常愤怒。但我现在真的为此感到自豪，因为能够成为其中的一部分是一件令人兴奋的事情。我觉得我因此变得更聪明了。但我当时确实很愤怒。
Angry in what terms?
哪方面的愤怒？
I was angry about losing the continuity of a community that I knew loved me.
我愤怒于失去了那个我知道爱我的社区的连续性。
Did you feel used?
你觉得被利用了吗？
I felt used, maybe, later because my father was a politician. So I later saw all these pictures in the paper. You know, "First Black Integrates the School." The newspaper coming, taking pictures of the American Negro family that's integration-bound. But other than the political ramifications, I don't think I felt used. Because you have to realize, too, my parents had a different kind of dream. They grew up in a fully segregated society, absolute segregation. We were born into this revolution and to this dream and this hope. And they wanted to realize it in whatever way they could. So I don't think I could even look back and find fault with any of their choices, because they were basically a product of all of those times.
我后来可能觉得被利用了，因为我父亲是位政治家。所以我后来在报纸上看到了所有这些照片。你知道，“第一个黑人融入学校”。报纸前来，给那个致力于融合的美国家庭拍照。但除了政治影响之外，我不认为我感到被利用。因为你也必须意识到，我的父母有另一种梦想。他们在完全种族隔离的社会中长大，绝对的隔离。我们出生在这场革命、这个梦想和这个希望中。他们想尽一切办法来实现它。所以我认为我甚至无法回过头来指责他们的任何选择，因为他们基本上是那个时代所有这些的产物。
So Karen Hutt told her church about the good things and the bad in her experience as a racial pioneer. And the reaction she got from the congregation at the First Unitarian Church was sort of surprising. Coming up, their reaction and their stories. It's Your Radio Playhouse.
所以凯伦·赫特向她的教会讲述了她作为种族先驱经历中的好事和坏事。她从第一一位论派教会的会众那里得到的反应有些令人惊讶。接下来是他们的反应和故事。这是您的广播剧场。
[MUSIC -- "DRIVE MY CAR" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 -- 披头士乐队的《开我的车》]
It's Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. So after Karen Hutt gave a sermon about her experience as the first black child to integrate the Philadelphia public schools, lots of members of the congregation came to her and said, well, I was the first black person in this neighborhood, or I was the first African-American to integrate this Girl Scout camp, or I was the first African-American in this department at the University of Chicago.
这是您的广播剧场。我是艾拉·格拉斯。所以凯伦·赫特发表了关于她作为第一个融入费城公立学校的黑人儿童的经历的布道后，很多会众成员来到她身边说，嗯，我是这个社区里的第一个黑人，或者我是第一个融入这个女童子军营地的非裔美国人，或者我是芝加哥大学这个部门里的第一个非裔美国人。
And Karen Hutt came to believe that for middle-class blacks, the story of the last 30 years is the story that begins with the sentence, I was the first black who. And so many stories were coming forward. First Unitarian is this integrated church and was a hotbed of political activism. In the '60s and the '70s, they hid Black Panthers. Old Mayor Daley would send his Red Squad to wait outside the church in cars. And lots of people at the First Unitarian Church had been involved in various integration struggles. And after Karen Hutt's sermon, they talked about doing an oral history of their experiences with integration. But they hadn't gotten around to it, and so we lent them a tape recorder, we at this radio show. And we asked them to do their oral history for our program. Karen Hutt did the interviews with a young woman named Laura Finnegan.
凯伦·赫特开始相信，对于中产阶级的黑人来说，过去30年的故事就是以“我是第一个黑人……”这句话开头的故事。有这么多故事浮出水面。第一一位论派教会是一个融合的教会，也是政治激进主义的温床。在60年代和70年代，他们藏匿过黑豹党成员。老戴利市长会派他的“红色小队”在教堂外的车里守候。第一一位论派教会里的许多人曾参与过各种融合斗争。凯伦·赫特布道后，他们谈到了要做一份关于他们融合经历的口述历史。但他们一直没腾出时间，所以我们，这个广播节目的工作人员，借给了他们一台录音机。我们请他们为我们的节目做口述历史。凯伦·赫特采访了一位名叫劳拉·芬尼根的年轻女性。
And Laura had the opposite experience Karen had as a child. Or, well, maybe it's the same experience. It depends how you see this. It was either the opposite experience or it was exactly the same experience. For much of her childhood, Laura's family was one of the few white families in South Shore, on the south side of Chicago.
劳拉有着与凯伦童年时截然不同的经历。或者，嗯，也许是一样的经历。这取决于你怎么看。这要么是截然不同的经历，要么是完全一样的经历。在劳拉童年的大部分时间里，她的家庭是芝加哥南区肖尔地区为数不多的白人家庭之一。
And by the time she was in eighth grade, she was one of two white children in her grade. And she describes it as just as just a confusing time. She describes it as just a confusing time. You do the grammar of that sentence. She says that it was just as confusing for her as it was for Karen Hutt. And sometimes she wished she were black so she could fit in better. It really created a lot of questions of who she was and who she should be, and how she should get along with people.
到她上八年级时，她是她年级里仅有的两名白人孩子之一。她将其描述为一段令人困惑的时光。她将其描述为一段令人困惑的时光。你处理一下那个句子的语法。她说，这对她来说和对凯伦·赫特来说一样令人困惑。有时她希望自己是黑人，这样她能更好地融入。这确实引发了很多关于她是谁、她应该成为谁，以及她应该如何与人相处的疑问。
When the violence in the neighborhood started to increase somewhat, we had been robbed at gunpoint. And it was a terrifying experience for me. And we would ask my family, are we going to move? And they would say, well, yeah, maybe we'll move. And the feeling that was conveyed was, well, if we move, then we're betraying this ideal of integration. And so at the time, I felt like, well, what is that ideal, and why are we here when I don't feel comfortable here all the time? Although I think on other levels, that idea that we were betraying the integration was also just an excuse for other personal reasons for why we were staying in the neighborhood.
当社区里的暴力开始有所增加时，我们遭遇了持枪抢劫。那对我来说是一次可怕的经历。我们会问家人，我们要搬家吗？他们会说，嗯，是的，也许我们会搬。传达出的感觉是，嗯，如果我们搬走，那我们就背叛了融合的理想。所以当时我觉得，嗯，那理想是什么，为什么当我不觉得在这里舒服时我们还要待在这里？尽管我认为在其他层面上，那种我们背叛了融合的想法也只是我们留在该社区的其他个人原因的借口。
Well, let's get to some of the tape that the two of you collected. One of the things that's interesting in the material that you've played me before coming in here is that generally, when we hear stories about being the first person to integrate a school or a neighborhood or a job situation, we're used to hearing horror stories. But in your interviews with members of your church, one of the things that's striking is how often people told you about moments and times where things worked out OK. And many people told you stories about somebody-- a boss or a coworker or a teacher or a friend-- who would look out for them and help get them jobs and appointments, help them find housing in an otherwise exclusive neighborhood that was trying to keep blacks out. Let me ask you to talk about some of that tape. Let's play a little bit of that.
嗯，让我们谈谈你们收集的一些录音。在来到这里之前你们放给我听的材料中，有趣的一点是，通常当我们听到关于成为第一个融入学校、社区或工作环境的人的故事时，我们习惯听到的是恐怖故事。但在你们对教会成员的采访中，引人注目的一点是，人们经常告诉你们事情进展顺利的时刻和时光。许多人告诉你们关于某个人——老板、同事、老师或朋友——会照顾他们，帮助他们获得工作和任命，帮助他们在原本试图将黑人拒之门外的排他性社区中找到住所的故事。让我请你谈谈其中的一些录音。让我们播放一小段。
OK. One of the people that I interviewed was a gentleman named Richard Jennifer. He's in his late 60's now, and he was an engineer for a subsidiary of the New York Times . He started working for the New York Times in the early '50s.
好的。我采访的人之一是一位名叫理查德·詹妮弗的绅士。他现在60多岁了，曾是《纽约时报》一家子公司的工程师。他是在50年代初开始为《纽约时报》工作的。
Race was not really a real concern, because we all tended to go around, pal around, play around with each other on our off hours, as well as our working days.
种族并不是一个真正的问题，因为我们都倾向于在下班后以及工作日里互相结伴、玩耍。
The interesting part about talking to Richard was that I learned his employer went to pretty great lengths to ensure that he was able to perform his job without the usual racial barriers impeding his ability to work.
与理查德交谈的有趣之处在于，我了解到他的雇主付出了很大的努力，以确保他能够在没有通常的种族壁垒阻碍其工作能力的情况下执行工作。
I was beginning to travel quite a bit and beginning to fly quite a bit. And somehow or other, it came up one day-- a question was asked of me. Dick, were you aware of the fact that there's been an entourage that went ahead of you to clear the road so that when you came to the hotels or whatever, there was no racial things involved? And I said, absolutely not. Because it just wasn't something that I was aware of.
我开始经常出差，也开始经常坐飞机。不知怎么的，有一天这个问题出现了——有人问我。迪克，你是否知道有一群随从走在你前面为你清路，这样当你到达酒店或任何地方时，就不会有任何种族问题？我说，绝对不知道。因为我根本没有察觉到这件事。
This next interview is with Finley Campbell, who's a professor at DeVry University and an activist in the Progressive Labor Party and very active in the social justice and environmental justice movement in our church. He's a civil rights activist that goes way back. And he also was shot in Tupelo, Mississippi in 1978.
接下来的采访对象是芬利·坎贝尔，他是德锐大学的教授，也是进步工党的激进分子，并且非常活跃于我们教会的社会正义和环境正义运动中。他是一位资深的民权活动家。1978年他在密西西比州的图珀洛被枪击。
Thinking about my experience with integration-- boy, there were a bunch of them. But the one that really sticks out is with my eating broiled rabbit with a Kentucky white brother named Junior Osbourne and his wife Rosemary. We were in this little town of Crawfordsville, Indiana. And I am the-- pardon the expression-- the black leader of the white folks. Because no one else wanted to reach out to the quote, "rednecks," unquote, except me. And there's a long story behind that.
思考我关于融合的经历——天哪，有很多。但真正让我记忆深刻的是与一位名叫朱尼尔·奥斯本的肯塔基州白人兄弟和他妻子罗斯玛丽一起吃炖兔肉的经历。我们当时在印第安纳州的一个名叫克劳福兹维尔的小镇。我是——请原谅我的表达——白人们的黑人领袖。因为除了我之外，没有人想去接触所谓的“红脖子”。这背后有一个很长的故事。
But right now, I'm eating dinner with Junior Osbourne and his wife Rosemary. And they bring out this stewed rabbit. It is so good. It is so delicious. And we're sitting there eating and talking, and talking about the food stamps program and things like that. And here is this guy who had been my nightmare, the redneck, drawling, working-class, white man with his white wife. And I'm sitting there, the radical supporter of the Black Panther party and all that stuff. And we're sharing this rabbit, and it is so good. And I said, how did you learn how to cook rabbit black style? And he said, what do you mean, black style? This is the way we white folks always cook it.
但现在，我正和朱尼尔·奥斯本和他妻子罗斯玛丽吃晚饭。他们端出了这道炖兔肉。它非常好吃。非常美味。我们坐在那里吃着聊着，谈论食品券计划之类的东西。而这就是那个曾经是我的噩梦、带有南方口音的蓝领白人男人和他的白人妻子。而我正坐在那里，是黑豹党的激进支持者，还有所有那些东西。我们正在分享这只兔子，它真的非常好吃。我说，你是怎么学会黑人风格烹饪兔子的？他说，你说黑人风格是什么意思？这是我们白人一直以来的做法。
And then it dawned on me that there is a Southern unity. There was always a form of cultural integration in the South, in which law acted as the wall to keep us divided, not personal desire or personal experience, for many people. Not all, but for many people. So that really stuck out in my mind, having that rabbit with Junior Osbourne. And that turned me completely away from any blackism I may have had about white folks who are not capable of making change.
然后我突然意识到，有一种南方统一。南方一直存在一种文化融合的形式，法律充当了分裂我们的墙，而不是个人的欲望或个人经验，对许多人来说是这样。并非全部，但对许多人来说是这样。所以这件事真的让我记忆犹新，和朱尼尔·奥斯本一起吃那只兔子。这让我彻底改变了对那些白人可能无法做出改变的任何黑人主义偏见。
All right. Well, let's get to some of the tougher experiences people had as racial pioneers.
好吧。那么，让我们来谈谈人们作为种族先驱所经历的一些更艰难的体验。
Well, Alex Poinsett is a longstanding member of our church. He used to be on the senior staff at Ebony Magazine as a writer. And he grew up in Inglewood in the '20s and '30s. And his first experience with integration was in high school. He says, among the people he knew, there was no real mixing. Blacks were just ignored. They stayed completely segregated when he was in the Navy. But he says some of his worst experiences were in college.
嗯，亚历克斯·波伊塞特是我们教会的长期成员。他以前是《乌木》杂志的资深编辑，担任作家。他在20年代和30年代在英格伍德长大。他第一次接触融合是在高中。他说，在他认识的人中，没有真正的混合。黑人只是被忽视。当他在海军时，他们完全保持隔离。但他说他最糟糕的一些经历是在大学里。
Well, the University of Illinois in Champaign was like North Mississippi. In my own case, I was obliged to sit-- the only black in a particular classroom-- and have to tolerate a professor telling a "nigger in the woodpile joke, and not realizing that, well, there's a black person here who might be offended by that. And after that particular session, I recall vividly him realizing that he had committed a faux pas and trying very, very hard to be apologetic and so forth. I just simply walked away from him.
嗯，香槟分校的伊利诺伊大学就像北密西西比。就我个人而言，我被迫坐在——我是特定教室里唯一的黑人——不得不忍受教授讲一个“木柴堆里的黑鬼”的笑话，却没有意识到，嗯，这里有一个可能会因此感到被冒犯的黑人。在那次特定的课程之后，我清楚地记得他意识到自己犯了社交失礼，并非常努力地道歉等等。我只是简单地离开了他。
Another person that we talked to was Charlotte Lackner. And she was also at the University of Illinois around the same time that Alex Poinsett was there.
我们交谈的另一个人是夏洛特·拉克纳。她和亚历克斯·波伊塞特在大约同一时间也在伊利诺伊大学。
People bought that anybody who really was straight with black people-- they were Communists or something. They were not people who were regular people, you know.
人们相信任何真正和黑人坦诚相待的人——他们就是共产党人什么的。他们不是普通人，你知道吗。
The blacks thought that?
黑人那么认为吗？
Yeah. Well, that's the way it was. When I went to Illinois, you couldn't live in the dorms. And at Chicago, you could. At Chicago you could live in the dorms. People used to call this a Communist school in those days. They were always talking about the Communists, the Reds, at Chicago.
是的。嗯，当时的情况就是这样。我上伊利诺伊大学时，你不能住在宿舍里。而在芝加哥，你可以。在芝加哥，你可以住在宿舍里。人们在那个年代经常称这为共产党学校。他们总是谈论芝加哥的共产党人，红党。
One of the other people that we talked to was Pauline McCool. She came to the church as a Sunday School teacher, but she ended up as the first black member of the First Unitarian Church in Chicago.
我们交谈过的另一个人是宝琳·麦库尔。她来教会时是一名主日学校老师，但最终成为了芝加哥第一一位论派教会的第一位黑人成员。
I said to my mom and dad, hey, I'm joining the church. Would you come and be with me? So I came over. And as I say, I ran in, raised my hand, was accepted. Unknown to me, on that day, the president of the board went to my father. And he had this conversation with him, stating that, oh, well, it's all right if the people who come are like your daughter.
我对我的爸爸妈妈说，嘿，我要加入教会。你们愿意来陪我吗？所以我过来了。正如我所说，我跑进去，举起手，被接受了。我不知道的是，那天董事会主席去找了我父亲。他和他就此进行了谈话，表示，哦，嗯，如果是像你女儿这样的人来，那是没问题的。
And what did he mean by, like your daughter? What was it that you--
他说的“像你女儿一样”是什么意思？你到底——
OK, I'm assuming that, since it was not told to me for several years later-- my father was quite hurt and knew that I was so enthusiastic about this church. Had I known that, I would have been disillusioned at a time when I was just forming an opinion of what was truth and what was reality and all the rest of it.
好的，我假设，因为这是几年后才告诉我的——我父亲很受伤，也知道我对这个教会如此热衷。如果当时我知道了，我会在我刚刚形成对什么是真理、什么是现实以及所有这些问题的看法时感到幻灭。
I'm sure that he was indicating that, OK, these are middle-class blacks. They own their own home. This girl is in college. She's going to be a professional. Whatever it meant, soon that faction left the church.
我肯定他在暗示，好吧，这些人是中产阶级黑人。他们有自己的房子。这个女孩在上大学。她将来会成为专业人士。无论这意味着什么，那个派系很快就离开了教会。
Alex Poinsett joined the church after Pauline McCool. But one of the things that he told us is that even though this pro-white faction left the church, it didn't really make that much of a difference.
亚历克斯·波伊塞特在宝琳·麦库尔之后加入了教会。但他告诉我们的事情之一是，尽管这个亲白人的派系离开了教会，但这并没有产生太大的影响。
We made some pretty good friendships here. Although I think many of the whites, even in those early days-- my wife felt church members were constantly on pins and needles, fearful of, on the one hand, being offensive to me or being so naive in their relationship with me as to inadvertently as to offend me. And the striking thing about that experience was that there was no concerted effort on the part of the church to "integrate," in quotes, the liturgy. Whatever black spirituality you brought to the church you parked outside of the door. You didn't bring it inside the door. I mean, if you were into hand-clapping and shouting and all of that, you left that part at the door. Because you would be an embarrassment, you see.
我们在这里结下了一些很好的友谊。尽管我认为许多白人，即使在早期——我妻子觉得教会成员一直如坐针毡，一方面害怕冒犯我，或者在与我的关系中表现得太天真，以至于无意中冒犯了我。那次经历中最令人震惊的是，教会方面没有做出任何协调一致的努力来“融合”（加引号）礼拜仪式。无论你带给教会什么样的黑人灵性，你都把它停在门外。你没有把它带进门。我的意思是，如果你喜欢拍手欢呼之类的一切，你得把那部分留在门外。因为那会让人尴尬，你看。
So that's one-way integration. That sort of integration says, you get like me, and whatever it is that is unique to you, you leave that behind. That's cultural suicide.
所以那是单向融合。那种融合意味着，你变得像我一样，而任何你独特的东西，你都要抛在脑后。那是文化自杀。
When civil rights began to emerge on the scene and began to be a factor and people began to think about it, there was a real effort to do things in an integrated. way
当民权运动开始出现在舞台上并开始成为一个因素，人们开始思考它时，人们确实做出了一些努力，以一种融合的方式做事。
This is George Reed, who was somebody that I interviewed at length. He was a chemist professionally. His experience was interesting, because he noted that in the beginning of the civil rights movement, there were a lot of goodwill gestures on the part of whites. And I think he felt that that was a good thing, but I think soon thereafter, and I mean over the course of years, those goodwill gestures began to diminish.
这是乔治·里德，我对他进行了深入采访。他职业上是一名化学家。他的经历很有趣，因为他注意到在民权运动开始时，白人方面有很多善意的姿态。我认为他觉得那是一件好事，但我认为在此之后不久，我的意思是经过多年，那些善意的姿态开始减少了。
We were invited to innumerable homes and events and whatnot in the suburbs, which I hated to go to because I always got lost. I just automatically go the wrong way, no matter how clear the directions are. And I always got lost, and I hated it. But the people were wonderful. And we had wonderful experiences, and we developed some very good friendships.
我们被邀请去郊区的无数家庭和活动等等，我讨厌去那里，因为我总是迷路。无论方向多么清晰，我总是自动走错路。我总是迷路，我讨厌那样。但人们很棒。我们有很棒的经历，也建立了一些很好的友谊。
And then, it was sort of like a flash in the pan. This sort of thing kind of faded away. I don't know whether it was due to the militancy of the blacks or whether the fact that the whites decided that it was too much trouble to be trying to do all these types of reaching-out things. They had enough to do in their own communities, with their own relationships and whatnot. I don't know what went on in the white mind. But I think in the black mind, probably, the attitude was, look-- I guess the best way I can describe it is related to the church.
然后，这有点像昙花一现。这种事情慢慢消失了。我不知道这是由于黑人的激进主义，还是由于白人认为尝试所有这些接触的事情太麻烦了。他们在自己的社区里，用他们自己的关系等等，已经有足够多的事情要做。我不知道白人的脑子里在想什么。但我认为在黑人的脑子里，态度可能很明确——我想我能描述的最佳方式与教会有关。
There was a sort of a meeting here at the church, downstairs in the basement. And we were all down there. And they had this person who was an expert at bringing these people together and getting people talking and thinking in buzz groups. And this thing went round and round and round. And I'll never forget that, because I was really upset and annoyed by the sort of cavalier attitude that many whites took about the sort of problems that we were trying to deal with. And finally I got up and said, listen, you can all walk out of here, and you're white and you can go do whatever you want. We will all walk out here, and we're still black. And we can't change that. So I think something did happen, that blacks decided, OK, look, no more of this accomodation stuff.
教会里举行过一次会议，就在地下室里。我们都在那里。他们有这样一位专家，擅长把这些人聚在一起，让人们在小组中讨论和思考。这事情转来转去。我永远不会忘记那一刻，因为我真的对许多白人对待我们试图处理的问题的那种漫不经心的态度感到心烦和恼火。最后我站起来说，听着，你们所有人都可以走出这里，你们是白人，你们可以去做任何你们想做的事。我们将所有人走出这里，我们仍然是黑人。我们无法改变这一点。所以我认为确实发生了某些事情，黑人们决定，好吧，看，不再有这种妥协的事情了。
Now, your church is a kind of living history of people who have tried this accommodation stuff, as George Reed says. There are a lot of people there who have really tried to make integration work in their lives. And given the ongoing public debate across the country about how to integrate, whether to integrate, whether it accomplishes anything worthwhile, I know that one of the things you asked your church members was, do they think it's worth it? Do they feel hopeful about integration? Do they think it's worth trying to do, given their experience?
那么，你的教会就像是一部尝试过这种妥协的活生生的历史，正如乔治·里德所说。那里有很多真正试图让融合在他们生活中发挥作用的人。考虑到全国范围内关于如何融合、是否要融合、它是否能带来任何有价值的成果的持续公开辩论，我知道你问过你的教会成员的一件事是，他们认为这值得吗？他们对融合感到希望吗？考虑到他们的经历，他们认为这值得尝试吗？
Well, this is Finley Campbell. Like I said earlier, he's an activist. And he's been involved in issues in the South and the North. And he has a lot to share here.
嗯，这是芬利·坎贝尔。就像我之前说的，他是位活动家。他参与过南方和北方的问题。他在这里有很多话要分享。
Integration never has been given a chance to really get off the ground. Remember, we had our last integration bill in '65, and then '66 the Black Power movement hit on the one end. And then Nixon hit in '68 on the other end. And then there is a white-skin privilege and this, that, and the other popped up. So we can no longer talk about a mass integrationist process. It was short-circuited. It was betrayed, to be blunt. So we've got to talk about integration moments. And not only have I seen them and experienced them, they fill me with hope.
融合从来没有被给予一个真正起步的机会。记住，我们在65年有了最后一份融合法案，然后66年黑人力量运动出现在一端。接着尼克松在68年出现在另一端。然后白人特权等等随之而来。所以我们不能再谈论大众融合进程了。它被缩短了。说得直白点，它被背叛了。所以我们必须谈论融合时刻。我不仅见过并经历过它们，它们还让我充满希望。
Now, what do you say to people who think that integration happened, and now we need to move into more segregated, separate kinds of worlds within the country? What do you say to them? Because that seems like a growing movement and commentary that a lot of people who are in the Afro-centric movement are talking about. What do you say about that?
那么，对于那些认为融合已经发生，现在我们需要在国家内部转向更隔离、更独立的生存方式的人，你怎么说？你对他们怎么看？因为这似乎是一个日益增长的运动和评论，许多参与非洲中心运动的人都在谈论这些。你对此怎么看？
Well, I say that many of those people never really experienced true down-home segregation. One of the top Afro-centrist persons, whose name I will not mention, was actually reared in a small town in Minnesota. So of course, with that kind of experience, being the only black, being around very few blacks, you're going to feel like, my God, let me get as black as I can. But those of us who came up through the old Southern days, with the black churches, black conventions, black schools-- we know what that's like. And we say, OK, now we're ready for the next flow.
嗯，我说很多人从未真正经历过真正的本土种族隔离。其中一位顶级的非洲中心主义者，名字我就不提了，实际上是在明尼苏达州的一个小镇长大的。所以当然，有了那样的经历，作为唯一的黑人，身边只有很少的黑人，你会觉得，天哪，让我尽可能地黑吧。但我们这些从南方旧时代走过来的人，经历过黑人教会、黑人公约、黑人学校——我们知道那是什么样子的。我们说，好吧，现在我们准备好迎接下一个潮流了。
Here's George Reed again.
这是乔治·里德再次发言。
I don't think that there is the sort of commitment in the white community as there was, earlier on, to trying to resolve it. I think maybe many people in the white community are running scared themselves. They want to survive. And whites have grown up in a society that condones bigotry in many respects.
我不认为白人社区里还有像早期那样试图解决这个问题的承诺。我想也许白人社区里的很多人自己也在害怕。他们想生存。而白人在一个在许多方面宽恕偏见的社会中长大。
And even whites who are liberated from that, they still have that baggage that they have to carry, just like blacks have a baggage that they have to carry that says that maybe they aren't up to it or that they're not deserving, or that this country doesn't belong to them like it belongs to everybody else. It's something that's so subtle and pervasive that it's going to take probably, even with the best intentions, a few generations to purge. }}}}}+
即使是从中解放出来的白人，他们仍然背负着必须携带的包袱，就像黑人必须背负一个包袱一样，这个包袱说他们可能无法胜任，或者他们不值得，或者这个国家不属于他们，就像它属于其他人一样。这东西太微妙且普遍，可能即使有最好的意图，也需要几代人才能根除。
This next tape is from John Rice. He came to the church, I think, in the '70s. So maybe he was hiding out. He was a Black Panther at the time, and a lot {"? heat on
接下来的这段录音来自约翰·赖斯。我想他在70年代来到教会。所以也许他是在躲避。他当时是黑豹党成员，很多人盯上他。
Him. So he came to our church and became involved in the activities there, and has been there ever since. And he said that he found the closest thing to real integration is in our church. In the outside world, he says, there's a lot of pressure on black people to be primarily identified only as black.
他来到我们的教会并参与了那里的活动，此后一直待在那里。他说他发现最接近真正融合的东西就在我们的教会里。他说，在外面的世界里，黑人承受着很大的压力，主要被认定为仅仅是黑人。
And I've had people from both communities who are-- well, you know you're black, don't you? Well, you know you're black, don't you? Well, you know you're a nigger, don't you? So in that sense, this Unitarian society gave me that freedom. I can be the asshole that I want to be. And nobody says, that's that black asshole. They just say, that's John. He's who he is, right? So I like that freedom.
我遇到过来自两个社区的人，他们是——嗯，你知道你是黑人，不是吗？嗯，你知道你是黑人，不是吗？嗯，你知道你是黑鬼，不是吗？所以从这个意义上说，这个一位论派协会给了我那种自由。我可以成为我想成为的混蛋。没有人说，那是那个黑人混蛋。他们只是说，那是约翰。他就是他自己，对吧？所以我喜欢那种自由。
One of the things, I think, that's made people in our church feel as if integration has worked is that people have substantial, authentic relationships with one another. And I think that's a really big difference, is that it's been a long haul. George is still there. Betty is still there. Charlotte is still there. All these folks are still around, struggling with these issues. Maybe not talking about them in the same tone, but they're still part of building a community. And I think the dream is still alive for many people, because of that church. But I think the authenticity of the relationships means that certain things have worked for them.
我认为，让教会里的人感到融合已经奏效的事情之一是，人们彼此之间有着实质性的、真实的联系。我认为这是一个很大的区别，那就是这是一个漫长的过程。乔治还在那里。贝蒂还在那里。夏洛特还在那里。所有这些人都还在那里，与这些问题抗争。也许不是用同样的语气谈论它们，但他们仍然是建立社区的一部分。我认为由于那个教会，许多人的梦想依然存在。但我认为关系的真实性意味着某些事情对他们确实奏效了。
Yeah. Do you want to say something, Laura?
是的。你想说点什么吗，劳拉？
Yeah. And I wanted to say, I think that is what sort of drew me to the church initially. I mean, I came to the church at a point where I thought, I live in two different worlds still, and it's driving me crazy. I live on the North side, and I grew up on the South side, and I swear to god they're still two different cities.
是的。我想说，我认为那正是最初吸引我来到教会的原因。我的意思是，我来到教会时，觉得，我仍然生活在两个不同的世界里，这让我快疯了。我住在北区，在南区长大，我向上帝发誓它们仍然是两个完全不同的城市。
And for me, I needed to reconcile that. And when I came to First Unitarian and I saw that people were still struggling with these issues, I thought, OK, I haven't lost my mind. People are still struggling with this. And maybe-- George talks about the burden that he felt that he thought that whites didn't share. And yet I think that in some small way, I feel that burden too, because I don't want to live in a world where we can only live in harmony if we live separately. It just doesn't feel right.
对我来说，我需要调和这一点。当我来到第一一位论派教会，看到人们仍然在与这些问题抗争时，我想，好吧，我没有疯。人们仍然在为此抗争。也许——乔治谈到了他感受到的那种他认为白人没有分担的负担。然而我认为在某种程度上，我也感受到了那种负担，因为我不想生活在一个只有通过分开居住才能和谐相处的世界里。这感觉不对。
Well, Laura Finnegan and Karen Hutt of the First Unitarian Church here in Chicago, thank you both very much.
那么，芝加哥第一论理派教堂的劳拉·芬尼根和凯伦·赫特，非常感谢二位。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It was fun.
这很有趣。
[MUSIC -- "STOP THAT ALABAMA BUS"]
[音乐 -- “阻止那辆阿拉巴马巴士”]
Well, earlier in our program, we heard a story by Claudia Perez about the year on 26th Street. And we thought that we would end our program with her as well. In reviewing what the year was like in her neighborhood, she also talked about what the year was like in her own life. And she said that her family has actually been pretty sad this year, because a cousin who everybody loved was shot last November, though she didn't want to talk more about that on the radio.
早些时候在我们的节目中，我们听到了克劳迪娅·佩雷斯讲述关于第26街一年的故事。我们想以她作为节目的结尾。在回顾她所在街区这一年来的情况时，她也谈到了自己生活中的这一年。她说，今年她们一家过得相当悲伤，因为大家都喜爱的一位表亲去年十一月被枪杀了，尽管她不想在广播里多谈这件事。
And this September, she said she had a kind of turning point in her life. She's 18, and she goes to an alternative high school called El Quarto Ano. And their funding was threatened and they were going to have to close. And her teachers said say she was instrumental in convincing the City College's Board of Directors to reinstate the funding. She spoke before them, and according to eyewitnesses, she captivated them, the way she spoke. And they did decide to give the money to keep the school open. And to give you a sense of the kind of person who she is becoming now, she decided her school should put out a newspaper, and so she put one out. She wanted to interview Luis Rodriguez, the local poet and author. And she did interview him, which she said for her was a big thing.
她说，今年九月，她的人生迎来了一个转折点。她今年18岁，在一所名为“第四年”（El Quarto Ano）的替代高中上学。学校的资金曾受到威胁，面临关闭的风险。她的老师说，她在说服城市学院董事会恢复拨款方面起到了关键作用。她在董事会面前发言，据目击者称，她的演讲深深地吸引了他们。最终他们决定拨出资金，让学校继续办下去。为了让你了解她现在正在成为什么样的人，她决定学校应该办一份报纸，于是她就办了一份。她想采访当地的诗人和作家路易斯·罗德里格斯。她确实采访了他，她说这对她来说是一件大事。
And when she and I were going around the discount mall interviewing people for her story, she was constantly giving advice to people, especially to the other teenagers when she would hear their situations. In the leather store, for example, she got into a big discussion with two different women, actually, about how to get college tuition.
当我和她在折扣购物中心为她的故事采访人们时，她不断地给人们提供建议，尤其是当她听到其他青少年的处境时。例如，在皮具店，她实际上和另外两位女性展开了一场激烈的讨论，内容是关于如何获得大学学费。
Yeah. If you have any good qualifications, like in doing anything, if you could finally get a scholarship, they'll help you. Anything. They're helping me try to get a savings bond from this thing called Latin something. And they give you at least $500. But that's good. Anything will help you. Try to write essays, or poems, anything, and enter them into-- sometimes you've got to look for scholarships. And just enter them. And you could get a-- especially because you're Hispanic. When you go to regular high school, they're not going to tell you that, because they don't want you to succeed. That's the thing. They don't want you to succeed.
是啊。如果你有任何好的资质，比如擅长做什么，如果你最终能获得奖学金，他们就会帮助你。任何事都行。他们正在帮我争取从一个叫“拉丁什么”的机构获得储蓄债券。他们至少给你500美元。但这很好。任何事情都会对你有帮助。试着写论文、写诗，什么都行，然后去参加——有时你得自己去寻找奖学金。只要去报名。你就有可能得到——尤其是因为你是西班牙裔。当你去普通高中时，他们不会告诉你这些，因为他们不希望你成功。事实就是这样。他们不希望你成功。
So when she was in our studio, we talked to her about her year. And hold on, let's get that tape cued up. And here we go.
所以当她在我们的演播室时，我们和她谈了谈她这一年。等一下，让我们把磁带准备好。开始了。
So how's your year been?
那么你这一年过得怎么样？
Up and down. Basically down, though.
起起落落。但基本上是下坡路。
In what way?
怎么说呢？
My dad's not here. He wasn't here for Christmas or Thanksgiving.
我爸爸不在。圣诞节或感恩节他都不在。
Because?
因为？
Personal reasons. Just personal reasons. I just know my dad is doing good. He'll be home soon.
个人原因。只是个人原因。我只知道我爸爸现在挺好的。他很快就会回家的。
He will be home soon.
他很快就会回家。
Real soon.
很快。
So what else happened in 1995?
那么1995年还发生了什么？
Well, at Christmas, I spent it with my best friend. Then I finally-- this guy came who I've liked for a long time. It's going to be four years. And I've seen him on Christmas Eve. It was good. It was nice, because I haven't seen him for probably about three months, maybe.
嗯，圣诞节我和我最好的朋友一起过的。然后我终于——我喜欢了很久的一个男孩来了。算起来快四年了。我在平安夜见到了他。感觉很好。很不错，因为我大概有三个月没见到他了，也许吧。
So you've liked him for a long time. You just haven't been seeing him. You haven't been going out or anything for a long time.
所以你喜欢他很久了。只是你们一直没见面。你们很久没有约会什么的了。
No, nothing like that. And I've seen him, and I was happy. I was real happy to have seen him. I thought, oh, good. I got a nice present. To me, that was a good present.
没有，没那回事。见到他时，我很高兴。见到他我真的非常开心。我想，哦，太好了。我收到了一个很棒的礼物。对我来说，那是个很棒的礼物。
Just to see him.
仅仅是见到他。
Yeah. And then two days later, I see him at the mall with another girl. And I guess to me, that was a sign to finally let go. And I wanted to cry, but it was just, like, there's no more tears left. I've learned to take the pain of being let down by him. I still think about him, but when he calls me, I'm not going to jump to it no more. I know it's not forever.
是啊。然后两天后，我在商场看到他和另一个女孩在一起。我想对我来说，那是一个终于该放手的信号。我想哭，但就好像，已经没有眼泪可以流了。我已经学会了接受被他伤害的痛苦。我仍然会想起他，但当他再打电话给我时，我不会再冲动了。我知道这不是永恒的。
You've been waiting a long time.
你等了很长时间。
A long time.
很长时间。
How long?
多久？
Three to four years. It's going to be four years.
三年到四年。快四年了。
And all through that time, you would see him every now and then.
在这段时间里，你们偶尔会见到对方。
Every now and then. I'll have my boyfriends, he'll have his girlfriends. But we still talk and everything. But to me, that's a great achievement, that I'm finally letting go of someone. Because-- how can I tell you? I've stopped a lot of things for him. I could have been somewhere else instead of here.
偶尔。我会交男朋友，他也会交女朋友。但我们仍然会交谈什么的。但对我来说，我终于能放下一个人的事实是一个巨大的成就。因为——我该怎么告诉你呢？我为他放弃了很多东西。我本可以去别的地方，而不是留在这里。
You mean living somewhere else, in another city.
你是说去别的地方生活，在另一个城市。
Mm-hmm. But I didn't. Because I would worry about where he was at, or what he was doing. So I came back. And now I'm just going to keep on walking.
嗯。但我没有。因为我会担心他在哪里，或者他在做什么。所以我回来了。现在我只想继续走我自己的路。
Now, for our story, you've brought in a CD. What is this?
现在，为了你的故事，你带来了一张CD。这是什么？
It's a song that I dedicated to that boy. To that young man. It's number four.
这是我献给那个男孩的一首歌。献给那个年轻人。是第四首歌。
The one who you're not going to feel bad about anymore.
那个你不再为他感到难过的男孩。
Yeah.
是啊。
All right, here we go.
好吧，开始吧。
Number four.
第四首。
All right, I'm cuing it up. Do you want to say anything else special to him before we play it?
好了，我正在调整播放。在播放之前，你还有什么特别想对他说的吗？
That he'll always be in my heart forever.
愿他永远在我心中。
OK. Who is this?
好的。这是谁的歌？
Um, it's-- oh, it's not on here.
嗯，是——哦，上面没写。
Is it on the thing?
在那个上面有吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
All right, hold on. Let me just check. Track number four. It says, "I Remember You, Homie." MC Blvd.
好了，等一下。让我检查一下。第四轨。上面写着，“我记得你，兄弟。”MC Blvd。
No, no, no. I'm sorry. It's number seven.
不，不，不。抱歉。是第七首。
Track number seven. "I Needed You Most." Marie.
第七轨。“我最需要你的时候。”玛丽。
Yeah.
对。
[MUSIC --  "I NEEDED YOU MOST" BY MARIE]
[音乐 -- 玛丽演唱的“我最需要你的时候”]
This is so sad.
这太令人难过了。
You see? That's to him.
看到了吗？那是给他的。
Today's program was produced by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel, Dolores Wilber, and Peter Clowney. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. The WBEZ executive officially overseeing this program is Torey Malatia.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，参与者包括阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、多洛雷斯·威尔伯和彼得·克劳尼。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·塔夫。负责监管本节目的WBEZ执行官是托雷·马拉蒂亚。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
We broadcast proudly from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more dramatic tales of This American Life.
我们自豪地从芝加哥WBEZ广播电台向您播出。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》的精彩故事回归。
You're getting so much publicity these days and even egghead papers are writing about you. Have you been a little bit worried that possibly you might be going over the top fairly soon?
你最近受到了很多关注，甚至连那些高深莫测的报纸都在写关于你的文章。你有没有一点担心自己可能很快就会做得过火了？
No.
没有。